episode 74 cryptocurrency and smart contracts with amy wan take it away patrick hey everyone uh we're here with Amy, the CEO of Sagewise. And we're glad to have you here of what is obviously a much discussed topic of the day with anything dealing with cryptocurrency seems to make people excited. And increasingly more peers and random people we meet tend to want to perk up and involve themselves in any conversation involving that, mostly because they think they're going to get rich. But anyways, so Amy, why don't you take a second to introduce yourself and tell us what you're doing? Sure. So thanks so much for having me on the show, guys. My name is Amy Wan. I am founder and CEO of Sagewise, which is a dispute resolution infrastructure for smart contracts. My background
第74集：加密货币与智能合约，嘉宾Amy Wan。帕特里克，请开始吧。嘿，大家好，我们今天请到了Sagewise的首席执行官Amy。我们很高兴你能来，因为这显然是当今讨论度极高的话题，任何与加密货币相关的事物似乎都能让人兴奋不已。越来越多的同行和我们遇到的普通人似乎都想打起精神，参与到任何涉及此话题的对话中，主要是因为他们觉得能发财。但无论如何，Amy，你能不能花点时间介绍一下你自己，告诉我们你在做什么？好的，非常感谢邀请我参加节目。我叫Amy Wan，是Sagewise的创始人和首席执行官，这是一家为智能合约提供争议解决基础设施的公司。我的背景是……
is actually, I'm an attorney by training. So, you know, I started my career off in the federal government doing international affairs, international regulatory and trade type issues. When I moved from DC back to California, there were obviously no free trade agreements to negotiate out here in California. And so, you know, kind of had to start my career all over again, was basically general counsel and employee number one of an early stage real estate crowdfunding startup. And from there, I went to become partner at a boutique securities law firm and got to a point in my career, really, where I just couldn't imagine practicing law the same way for the next 30, 40 years. So I actually left my partnership at my law firm and started this company. And the original purpose of this company was really to automate
其实，我受过法律专业训练。所以，我的职业生涯始于联邦政府，从事国际事务、国际监管和贸易类问题。当我从华盛顿特区搬回加州时，加州显然没有自由贸易协定需要谈判。所以，我不得不重新开始我的职业生涯，基本上是在一家早期房地产众筹初创公司担任总法律顾问，也是那里的第一位员工。从那以后，我成为了一家精品证券律师事务所的合伙人，并在职业生涯中达到了一个阶段，我真的无法想象在接下来的30到40年里以同样的方式从事法律工作。所以我离开了律师事务所的合伙人职位，创办了这家公司。这家公司的初衷其实是为了自动化……
my job as an attorney. So that's what I did. I pushed out software that would automate the drafting of small, you know, real estate funds, real estate, private equity funds, crowdfunding, syndication funds. But basically last year, I started getting a lot of calls from people who wanted to do an ICO. An ICO is an initial coin offering. And so I looked into the space and, you know, more than, you know, I basically looked into the space and I thought there was something fundamentally wrong with the space, right? If you were watching this entire space last summer, you would basically see ICOs come out. And in the first 15 minutes, they would get hacked two to $3 million. And the founders would sit there and shrug their shoulders and say, oops, sorry,
我作为律师的工作。这就是我所做的。我推出了可以自动化起草小型房地产基金、房地产私募股权基金、众筹和银团基金文件的软件。但基本上去年，我开始接到很多想进行ICO的人打来的电话。ICO就是首次代币发行。所以我研究了这个领域，我基本上深入研究了这个领域，并认为这个领域存在根本性的错误。如果你去年夏天一直在观察整个领域，你会看到ICO不断涌现。在最初的15分钟内，它们就会被黑客攻击，损失200到300万美元。而创始人就坐在那里耸耸肩说，哎呀，抱歉，
there's nothing we can do. I thought, gosh, this is really strange. In the real world, when you lose two to three million dollars, you get slapped with a lawsuit. And so I started digging into why and basically realized that smart contracts are, in many cases, not actually very smart. In fact, they're incredibly stupid, which is why we're doing what we're doing now. We're basically building an infrastructure or a layer for dispute resolution in case smart contracts fail. So that was obviously like a lot of stuff. So, you know, kind of taking it back a step, can you sort of give a high level overview? You know, when we say cryptocurrency, blockchain and, you know, kind of especially why people might just shrug their shoulders and sort of give up, you know, things like decentralized immutability.
我们无能为力。我觉得，天哪，这太奇怪了。在现实世界中，当你损失200到300万美元时，你会面临诉讼。所以我开始深究原因，并基本意识到智能合约在很多情况下实际上并不那么“智能”。事实上，它们极其愚蠢，这就是我们现在做这件事的原因。我们基本上是在为智能合约失败的情况构建一个基础设施或争议解决层。这显然包含了很多内容。所以，让我们退一步，你能从宏观层面概述一下吗？当我们说加密货币、区块链时，特别是为什么人们可能会耸耸肩并放弃，比如去中心化和不可篡改性这些概念。
Can you sort of give us like a brief overview of kind of what those things are supposed to mean and then, you know, kind of why you find that they aren't always what people assume? Yeah, sure. So blockchain, if you're going to define blockchain, I think we really also need to sit here and define what a distributed ledger is, right? So think about, I don't know, your bank account, for example, you kind of have a ledger there or an accounting of all the transactions you've had, but it's centralized, you know, you either you or your accountant or someone has one copy of this. And if that copy is wrong, or if that copy is forged or fraudulent, then there's obviously going to be a problem. Blockchain is the technology that kind of underlies all this cryptocurrency stuff that everyone's talking about. And what it really is, is it's meant to be a trustless system, right?
你能简要概述一下这些术语的含义，以及为什么你认为它们并不总是人们所假设的那样吗？好的，没问题。关于区块链，如果你要定义它，我认为我们还需要先定义什么是分布式账本。想想你的银行账户，你那里有一个账本，记录了你所有的交易，但它是中心化的，要么是你，要么是你的会计，或者某个人拥有一份副本。如果那份副本是错误的，或者被伪造、欺诈，那显然会有问题。区块链是支撑所有这些人们谈论的加密货币事物的技术。它本质上应该是一个无需信任的系统。
And I say trustless and it's also decentralized because it basically works like this. Instead of one person having one copy of a ledger, instead think of it as maybe we've got this whole network of people, right? And every time a transaction happens, that transaction gets recorded to the ledger, but it doesn't get recorded to one ledger. It gets recorded to everyone's ledger at the same time. And the ledgers are always syncing, right? And so there's not one person with a right or wrong copy. Everyone has the same copy and it can't really be forged because everyone's copy is the same.
我之所以说“无需信任”且“去中心化”，是因为它的工作原理是这样的：不是一个人拥有一份账本，而是想象我们拥有一个庞大的人员网络。每当发生交易时，该交易都会被记录到账本中，但它不会只记录到一个账本上，而是同时记录到每个人的账本上。账本始终在同步。所以没有一个人拥有正确或错误的副本。每个人都有相同的副本，而且它很难被伪造，因为每个人的副本都是一样的。
So that's basically the premise of blockchain distributed ledger technology now cryptocurrency is one use case of blockchain and and you can really have many different use cases it I think cryptocurrency is just you know one of the more popular ones because basically you, you know, back in, I think was it 2008, 2009, an anonymous person, everyone calls them Satoshi, basically came out with this white paper that introduced this technology. And the way they introduced it was through a cryptocurrency. And that cryptocurrency, as everyone knows today, is Bitcoin, right? And so this anonymous person put this thing
这就是区块链分布式账本技术的前提。现在，加密货币是区块链的一个用例，你可以有许多不同的用例。我认为加密货币只是其中比较流行的一个，因为基本上，在2008年或2009年，一个匿名人士，大家都叫他中本聪，发布了一份引入这种技术的白皮书。他们引入它的方式是通过一种加密货币。而这种加密货币，正如今天每个人所知，就是比特币。所以这个匿名人士把这个东西……
out into the world and slowly, slowly, slowly it began to gain adoption. But then when people were reading about it, they're like, well, I'm'm gonna make my own cryptocurrency and so that's why you have these things called alt coins alternative coins right so you know um you not only have have bitcoin today you've got things like dogecoin and all these other coins so there's a lot of different types of cryptocurrencies so um sorry so one thing so this is one thing I've always kind of wondered is going back to the blockchain, what's to stop me and like, you know, some of my friends, or maybe I make a post on Facebook, I get everyone who's following me on Facebook, what's to stop all of us from getting together, maybe me and 100 people and saying, you know, Amy Wan gave me all of her money. Or like if all of us, you know, somehow said that
推向了世界，它慢慢地开始获得采用。但当人们读到它时，他们会想，我要创造我自己的加密货币，这就是为什么会有所谓的“山寨币”（替代币）。所以，今天你不仅有比特币，还有狗狗币和其他所有这些币，所以有很多不同类型的加密货币。抱歉，有一件事我一直很好奇，回到区块链，有什么能阻止我和我的一些朋友，或者也许我在Facebook上发个帖子，让所有关注我的人一起，比如我和100个人聚在一起说，Amy Wan把她所有的钱都给了我。或者如果我们所有人……
and agreed to that, the hundred of us, you know, what's to stop that from being reality? In other words, like who's watching the Watchmen or who are the Watchmen, I guess? Like what's to stop, you know, like a group of people from just saying something happened when it really didn't? So, you know um right now we're talking about public blockchains as opposed to private ones and i can talk about private ones
都同意这一点，我们这100个人，有什么能阻止它成为现实呢？换句话说，谁在监督监督者，或者谁是监督者？有什么能阻止一群人仅仅因为说某事发生了而实际上并没有发生呢？所以，现在我们讨论的是公有区块链，而不是私有区块链，我可以谈谈私有区块链……
a little bit but public ones are basically you know it's exactly as it sounds like it's out in the public and everyone who's in this network has a copy of this ledger and it's continually sinking. Right. You might not know who is who are the other nine parties or nine hundred parties or nine thousand parties that have this ledger, which makes it very difficult to basically create some sort of fraudulent transaction on the blockchain. Now, there are private blockchains. So there's a lot of like Fortune 500 companies and things of that sort that are more so looking to private blockchains. The reason why they're specifically interested in private blockchains is because you still do have a little bit more of a degree of
稍微谈谈，但公有区块链基本上就像听起来那样，它是公开的，网络中的每个人都有这个账本的副本，并且它在持续同步。你可能不知道其他9方、900方或9000方是谁，这使得在区块链上制造某种欺诈交易变得非常困难。现在，有私有区块链。有很多财富500强公司等更倾向于私有区块链。他们之所以对私有区块链特别感兴趣，是因为你确实拥有更高程度的……
control, right? And so if there truly is a mistake, there actually is a way to go back and edit it a little bit more. I think the other thing, Jason, is what you find is partly the big criticism in the public news that has come up with Bitcoin about mining is because of that. So the idea is that you have to do a bunch of work in order to kind of commit a transaction to the chain. And so in order to kind of rewrite history, you would need more than 51% of that capacity in order to form a majority. And if you were going to do that, you have two problems. One, it's very expensive to do that. And the second thing is now you've sort of undermined the integrity of the very thing you're trying to steal. So you've spent all this money to commit this fraud. But at the same time,
控制权。所以如果真的出现错误，确实有一种方法可以回去进行编辑。我认为另一件事是，Jason，你发现关于比特币挖矿的很大一部分批评是因为这个。所以这个想法是，你必须做大量的工作才能将交易提交到链上。因此，为了重写历史，你需要超过51%的算力才能形成多数。如果你要这样做，你会遇到两个问题。第一，这样做非常昂贵。第二，你现在已经破坏了你试图窃取的东西的完整性。所以你花了很多钱来实施这种欺诈。但同时，
you now hold bitcoins that you stole from Amy that are worth less because you crashed the market because everyone goes, oh, now we got hacked. Oh, I see. So and and then there's other ways of sort of like proof of stake you'll hear about or whatever that I think are trying to solve the same problem. But it basically amounts to people having to spend resources to alter something where then they actually undermine their own work in doing so i see i see so uh got it that makes sense yeah so so for me to uh pretend like amy sent me all of her money i need to sort of reverse engineer her private key and that would take so much effort that uh if someone could do that then the whole thing kind of falls apart well you know the difficulty I think aside from
你现在持有的从Amy那里偷来的比特币价值更低了，因为你导致市场崩盘，每个人都会说，哦，现在我们被黑了。哦，我明白了。所以，还有其他方式，比如你听说的“权益证明”之类的，我认为它们试图解决同样的问题。但归根结底，人们必须花费资源来改变某些东西，而这样做实际上破坏了他们自己的工作。我明白了，明白了。所以，为了假装Amy把她所有的钱都给了我，我需要反向工程她的私钥，这需要付出巨大的努力，如果有人能做到这一点，那么整个系统就会崩溃。嗯，你知道，我认为除了资源问题之外的困难是……
the resources issue is you know you would have to attempt to go and change everyone else's record or transactional history, that ledger, right? And that is so difficult. I mean, there have been instances in which this has been done before. So for example, every time they hard fork Ethereum, right? Ethereum is a very popular blockchain or protocol. They've done it in the past very rarely, very sparingly. But when they have done it, it was to fix a big thing that was not meant to happen. Got it. Makes sense. And so, yeah, that's a good point. So you were talking first about cryptocurrency, but then smart contracts. How do smart contracts differ from cryptocurrency? A smart contract is basically, I would say it's like an English contract except written in code.
你必须尝试去改变其他所有人的记录或交易历史，那个账本。这太难了。我的意思是，以前确实发生过这种情况。例如，每次他们对以太坊进行硬分叉时。以太坊是一个非常流行的区块链或协议。他们过去很少这样做，非常谨慎。但当他们这样做时，是为了修复一件本不该发生的大事。明白了。有道理。所以，你先谈了加密货币，然后是智能合约。智能合约与加密货币有何不同？智能合约基本上，我会说它就像一份英文合同，只是用代码编写的。
So I once heard someone say like they thought the name of it was not great. They would rather call it programmable contracts. And I would tend to agree. A smart contract is really nothing more than a set of if-then clauses, right? And so a smart contract is meant to be self-executing and immutable. So if you and I entered a smart contract to say, hey, the Raiders, you know, let's bet one Bitcoin on who's going to win the Raiders versus whatever game. And if the Raiders win, you get the Bitcoin. If the other team wins, I get the Bitcoin, right? And so when the Raiders play, there's going to be some certain outcome
我曾经听人说，他们认为这个名字起得不好。他们宁愿称之为“可编程合同”。我倾向于同意。智能合约实际上只不过是一组“如果-那么”条款。所以智能合约应该是自动执行且不可篡改的。如果你和我签订了一份智能合约，说，嘿，突袭者队（Raiders），我们赌一个比特币，看谁能赢下突袭者队对阵某某队的比赛。如果突袭者队赢了，你得到比特币。如果另一支球队赢了，我得到比特币。所以当突袭者队比赛时，会有某种确定的结果……
and the smart contract would automatically know okay the raiders won so you get the bitcoin it's it's just a set of if then clauses really i see so the smart contracts like somehow has some interface to some other phenomena in the world like like there's maybe the nfl has an api or something that. And the smart contract has an interface to that. And as soon as that updates, the smart contract fires. Yeah, I mean, that's one way you could do it. So there are these cons, there's a bunch of different things, actually. So one concept is that of an oracle.
智能合约会自动知道，好的，突袭者队赢了，所以你得到比特币。它只是一组“如果-那么”条款。我明白了，所以智能合约以某种方式与世界上的其他现象有接口，比如NFL有一个API之类的。而智能合约与该接口相连。一旦更新，智能合约就会触发。是的，我的意思是，这是一种实现方式。所以确实有各种各样的东西。一个概念是“预言机”（Oracle）。
An oracle is some sort of, you know, third party that verifies some sort of facts. You could go to Oracle and use that to see, you know, whether the Raiders won. At the same time, you can use nodes, right? So there's a lot of different ways you can do this. But that's, you know, I'm highly simplifying all of this. But that's basically you know, I'm highly simplifying all of this, but that's basically it in a nutshell. I think one way you might be able to think of a smart contract that really kind of is in the real world today is, you know, when you go and you trade stocks and you say, hey, when ABC stock goes above $20, I want to sell it or something like that, right? And so the minute it goes above $20, it automatically executes.
预言机是某种验证事实的第三方。你可以去预言机那里，用它来看看突袭者队是否赢了。同时，你可以使用节点。所以有很多不同的方法可以做到这一点。但我是在高度简化所有这些。但本质上就是这样。我认为你可以把当今现实世界中的智能合约想象成，当你去交易股票时，你说，嘿，当ABC股票超过20美元时，我想卖掉它之类的。所以一旦它超过20美元，它就会自动执行。
Oh, okay. That makes sense. Makes sense. So you said, you know, you kind of think that the smart contracts are often dumb or, you know, that they're just programmable things. And I think that makes sense that, you know, like you said, they're just a program. They're just doing what they're being programmed to do. But what do you kind of find as like a misconception around this sort of, I don't know if it's serious or not, but the, you know, internet's view that, oh, we won't need lawyers anymore because the contract is code and the code is the contract.
哦，好的。这说得通。有道理。所以你说，你认为智能合约通常很笨，或者它们只是可编程的东西。我认为这说得通，它们只是一个程序。它们只是在做它们被编程要做的事情。但你认为围绕这种——我不知道这是否严肃——互联网的观点，即“我们不再需要律师了，因为合同就是代码，代码就是合同”，有什么误解吗？
Yeah. So there's definitely philosophy that code is law, right? But I think if you've seen what's happened over the past two years, there's a lot of problems with that philosophy. And so I think the first big example of this was the DAO. The DAO was the Decentralized Autonomous Organization. It was basically a decentralized fund, right? People pooled money together, and then they were all supposed to vote about, hey, let's fund this project, or no, let's fund this project. And the rules of the community were all written in code in a gigantic smart contract, except the problem was that the smart contract you know I guess just wasn't really well written and so one community member went in and saw a security vulnerability in the code and so they basically executed a hack against the smart contract now it wasn't against the terms of the smart contract but it was certainly against the intent of the smart contract, but it was certainly against the intent of the smart contract.
是的。绝对有一种“代码即法律”的哲学。但我认为如果你看看过去两年发生的事情，这种哲学存在很多问题。我认为第一个大例子是DAO。DAO是去中心化自治组织。它基本上是一个去中心化基金。人们把钱汇集在一起，然后他们都应该投票决定，嘿，我们要资助这个项目，或者不，我们要资助那个项目。社区的规则都写在巨大的智能合约代码中，但问题是智能合约……你知道，我想它写得并不好，所以一位社区成员进去发现了代码中的安全漏洞，于是他们基本上对智能合约执行了一次黑客攻击。现在，这并不违反智能合约的条款，但肯定违背了智能合约的意图。
And the result of that was basically that the DAO got drained of, what, $50, $60 million worth of funds at the time. And in order to, you know, prevent the hacker from getting away with this, they had to go hard fork Ethereum. So, you know, that happened in 2016. You know, 50, 60 million dollars was lost in or almost lost in that transaction had they not reversed it or hard forked it. 2017 got even worse, right? I recently saw a statistic that the equivalent value of 1 billion US dollars was lost in smart contracts in 2017. Lots of ICOs got hacked, right? And so what you're starting to see is that smart contracts, in fact, maybe this whole immutability thing is not such a good thing, right? You've got coding errors, for example, you know, developers often are like, you know, fail fast and iterate. But if that's what you're doing with a smart contract, then a lot of smart contracts are going to fail from sloppy coding,
结果是DAO在当时被抽走了价值5000万到6000万美元的资金。为了防止黑客逃脱，他们不得不对以太坊进行硬分叉。所以，这发生在2016年。如果他们没有撤销或硬分叉，那笔交易中损失了5000万到6000万美元。2017年情况更糟。我最近看到一个统计数据，2017年智能合约中损失了相当于10亿美元的价值。很多ICO被黑了。所以你开始看到，智能合约，事实上，也许整个不可篡改性并不是一件好事。你有编码错误，例如，开发人员通常说“快速失败并迭代”。但如果你对智能合约这样做，那么很多智能合约会因为草率的编码而失败。
then you've got, you know, security vulnerabilities, you know, a lot of people today using smart contracts, they will go get a security audit on the smart contract, but that only will detect the presence of vulnerabilities. It won't necessarily detect or guarantee the absence of them, right? And then the third thing really is that the more complex people are writing their smart contracts to be, the more people are going to modify, need to modify, amend, or terminate their smart contracts to be the more people are going to modify need to modify amend or terminate these smart contracts because guess what you know the world is it's it's not just a yes-no black-and-white place it's actually really complex things happen situations change right and so know, having been an attorney who's dealt with
然后你有安全漏洞。今天很多使用智能合约的人会去对智能合约进行安全审计，但这只会检测到漏洞的存在。它不一定会检测或保证它们不存在。第三点是，人们编写的智能合约越复杂，他们就越需要修改、修订或终止这些智能合约，因为猜猜怎么着，世界不仅仅是一个“是”或“否”、非黑即白的地方，它实际上非常复杂，事情会发生，情况会改变。所以，作为一个处理过……
a lot of contracts, dealt with a lot of disputes, you see a lot of different things, right? And so that's really the problem that we see today with smart contracts. So, you know, I've always kind of wondered, which is, you know, you see someone will post up that they're you know exploring using smart contracts for escrow for real estate um how does how does so i mean a kind of like do you have any thoughts on that it's a good idea bad idea that seems awesome i don't know whatever but also like how does it end up interfacing because obviously the you know u.s law or the state law or whatever applicable law might be i'm using the wrong terms, you can correct them, doesn't have in there what to do in case of problems in a smart contract for escrow of
很多合同、处理过很多纠纷的律师，你会看到很多不同的事情。所以这确实是我们今天在智能合约中看到的问题。所以，我一直很好奇，你看到有人会发帖说他们正在探索将智能合约用于房地产托管。你对此有什么想法吗？是个好主意还是坏主意？这看起来很棒，我不知道。但它最终是如何对接的？因为显然，美国法律或州法律或任何适用的法律——我用的术语可能不对，你可以纠正我——并没有规定在房地产托管的智能合约出现问题时该怎么办。当前的实际法律是如何与这种尝试做事情的新方式对接的？好的。关于智能合约，正如你所说，有趣的是它可以容纳资产，它可以容纳代币或加密货币等等。所以智能合约，在某些方面，你可以把它想象成托管，只是它应该是自动执行的。它不是中心化的。如果你去一家高度中心化的传统托管公司，它最终是由人类运营的。所以在某些方面，智能合约可以充当托管。现在，关于在房地产领域应用它，我确实接到很多人的电话，他们说……
real estate. How does the current actual law of the land interface with this new way of trying to do stuff? Sure. So the interesting thing about smart contracts, as you say, is it can house assets, right? It can house tokens or cryptocurrency or whatever, right? And so a smart contract, in some ways, you can think of it like an escrow, except it's supposed to be self-executing. It's not centralized, right? If you go to a traditional escrow company that's highly centralized, it's run by human beings at the end of the day. So in some ways, a smart contract can act as escrow. Now, with regard to applying it in the real estate space, I actually get a lot of calls from folks who are like,
哦，我们想做某种房地产ICO，做一些关于房地产、智能合约和区块链的事情，等等。很多时候，我认为很多人要么真的不知道区块链或智能合约是做什么的，要么他们真的不懂房地产。我认为，你当然可以使用智能合约来托管这些资金。但同时，房地产交易之所以需要这么长时间，并不一定是因为托管。这是因为需要完成所有的尽职调查。你必须走访房子，确保环境没问题，没有损坏。
oh, we want to do some sort of real estate ICO, something with the real estate and smart contracts and blockchain, blah, blah, blah. Um, a lot of these times, I think a lot of people either don't really know what blockchain or smart contracts do or, you know, or they don't really understand real estate. I think a lot of, you know, you certainly can use a smart contract to escrow those funds. But at the same time, you know, the reason why real estate transactions take such a long amount of time isn't necessarily because of escrow. It's because of all the due diligence that needs to be done, right? You've got to walk through the house. You've got to make sure environmentally it's fine. There's no damage.
你必须去获取房地产产权。你必须获得产权保险，所有这些事情。所以我认为说在智能合约中为房地产交易托管资金将治愈我们所有的问题，并使房地产交易变得快得多，这有点过于简化了。同样，我是从美国房地产交易运作的角度来说的。现在，关于……是的，它在世界各地的运作方式并不一定相同。所以这引出了我的下一点，
You have to go get real estate title. You have to get title insurance, all these things. So I think to say that escrowing funds for real estate transactions in smart contracts will cure all our problems and make real estate transactions go so much faster. I think that's a little bit of an oversimplification. And again, I'm speaking from a perspective of how real estate transactions work in the United States. Now, with respect to, yeah, it doesn't necessarily work the same in all countries across the globe, right? And so that brings me to my next point,
即法律如何对待它。目前，我们正处于整个行业的起步阶段。我不认为法律体系已经真正跟上，并真正考虑了他们将如何对待智能合约或数字交易。我的意思是，我们现在有了《电子签名法》，它基本上允许电子签名，这花了一段时间。法律要跟上围绕区块链和智能合约的所有这些东西还需要一段时间。特拉华州，我会说实际上是一个真正走在前面的司法管辖区。他们最近批准了一项法律，允许公司……基本上在区块链上，如果你愿意的话。所以他们想得很远。然后……
which is in terms of how the law treats it. Right now, we are at the very beginning stages of this entire industry. And I don't think the legal system has really caught up and has really contemplated how they're going to treat smart contracts or, you know, digital transactions. I mean, you know, we now have the e-sign act, which, you know, basically allows for e-signatures that took a while. It's going to take a while for the law to catch up with all the stuff around blockchain and smart contracts right delaware i would say is actually one jurisdiction that is really ahead of the curve um they recently approved a law that allows for uh corporations to um you know basically be on the blockchain if you will um will. So they're thinking a lot ahead. And then there's
世界上肯定还有其他国家真正开始研究这个问题。但你是对的，这是一个相当复杂的问题。所以也许这会与你提到的争议解决内容相衔接。但我一直试图弄清楚的一件事是，为了解释，我会尝试一下，我可能会做得不好，你可以纠正我。所以托管，它的意思是，如果你去买房子，会有很多人必须做很多工作才能让买房成为可能。所以直到交易完成，想买房子的人基本上会把一些钱交给第三方，一个托管人，一个持有托管账户的人。你把钱放在那个托管账户里。一旦钱在那里，你基本上就无法再访问它了……
certainly other countries across the world that are really starting to look into this. But you're right, it is a pretty complex issue. So maybe this will dovetail into the dispute resolution stuff you mentioned. But the thing that I've always tried to sort of get my head around is, so I guess to explain kind of, and I'll do my job, I'll try it, and I'll probably do a bad job and you can fix it. But so escrow, what that sort of means is like if you go to buy a house, that there's going to be a lot of people who are going to have to do a lot of work to kind of allow house buying to happen. And so until the transaction is complete, the person who wants to buy the house essentially puts some money away in the hands of a kind of third party, an escrow, someone who holds the escrow account. You put the money there in this escrow account. And once the money's there, you kind of no longer have access to it
作为买房的人。但你从谁那里买房的人也无法访问它。然后每个人都会经历这种所谓的“善意努力”，试图让销售发生。最后，理想情况下，每个人都同意，耶，我们现在准备好了。托管资金被转移给某一组人，但基本上是从买方转移给卖方。你之所以想要一个托管账户，是因为当那些现实世界的事情发生时，你知道钱不会消失。但对我来说，我一直试图弄清楚的另一件事是，如果你用智能合约做这件事，比如，我发送一些以太坊到一个合约，直到Jason和我使用我们的私钥进行某种交易，说钱应该被释放，它就会被保存在那里。
as the person buying the property. But the person who you're buying from also doesn't have access to it. And then everyone goes through this sort of, I guess you would call it good faith effort of trying to make the sale happen. And then at the end, ideally, everyone agrees that, yay, we're now we're ready. And the escrow money gets transferred to some set of parties, but basically to the person who is selling the thing from the person who's buying it. And the reason why you might want an escrow account there is that while those real world things are happening, you know that the money is not going to go away or disappear. But for me, the other thing that I've always tried to figure out is if you kind of do this with a smart contract, like, you know, I send some Ethereum to a contract and until both Jason and I use our private keys to make some transaction that says the money should be released, it gets held there.
但问题是，当我们有分歧时会发生什么？通常，据我所知，持有托管的人将负责尝试采取第一步，试图弄清楚托管账户里的钱应该怎么处理。但在智能合约方面，我一直觉得这说不通，你确实需要一个人来与律师、法律以及当Jason和我对尝试做这件事时实际发生的事情产生争议时会发生的事情进行对接。是的，我的意思是，我自己也无法解释得更好。所以，尽管我认为肯定有技术人员认为，哦，一切都应该是不可篡改的。
But the problem is like what happens when we have a disagreement? So normally, as far as I understand it, the person holding the escrow would be responsible for taking a first pass at trying to, you know, figure out what should happen to the money that's in the escrow account. But in terms of a smart contract, it never made sense to me, like, you kind of do want a human there to sort of interface with the, you know, attorneys, the law, the kind of thing that would happen when Jason and I have a dispute about what actually happened while we were trying to do this. Yeah, I mean, I really couldn't have explained it better myself, right? And so, you know, as much as I think there's definitely technologists out there who are like, oh, everything should be immutable.
一切都应该是自动执行的。我们不应该有人类参与。事实是，世界是一个非常复杂的地方。我会让你知道，人类是非常复杂、有创造力的生物。惊喜吧！所以，我的意思是，你不会相信我在职业生涯中看到的事情。是的，人们在试图摆脱这些事情时非常有创造力。这就是为什么我认为在所有那些边缘情况下，争议解决确实是必要的，因为……
Everything should be self-executing. We shouldn't have human beings involved. The truth is the world is a very complex place. And I will let you know that, you know that human beings are very complex creative creatures. Surprise! Right? And so, I mean, you would not believe the things I have seen in my career. Like, yeah, people are very, very creative in trying to get out of these things. And so that's why you will have situations, I think, where dispute resolution really is necessary for all of those edge cases where, you know,
事情并非非黑即白。是的，这说得通。我认为，将此与我们之前做的一集联系起来，我谈到了现在，比如人工智能在游戏等方面的最新进展，基本上是预测你的对手想要什么。事实证明，这就像——这正在彻底改变人工智能。它也正在彻底改变经济学等领域。
things just aren't black and white. Yeah, that makes sense. I think that, you know, tying this into an episode we did earlier where I talked about now, like, the latest in AI for games and things like that is, is basically predicting what your opponent wants. It turns out this is like, and this is revolutionizing AI. It's also revolutionizing economics and things like that.
基本上人们过去常说，哦，让我们找到纳什均衡，或者让我们进行完美的拍卖等等。这和你说的有点像，人们觉得有一种纯粹的解决方案。人们现在发现的是，不，事物的价格在很大程度上基于心理学，人们在拍卖中的行为并不像约翰·纳什所希望的那样。所以真正重要的是模拟相关人员，了解他们的价值，无论这是否理性，然后在这些限制内工作。所以如果我们处于拍卖情况，那就是对其他人正在采取的任何拍卖策略做出最佳反应。
And basically people used to say, oh, let's find the Nash equilibrium or let's get the perfect auction and all of these things. And it's kind of similar to what you were saying that people felt like there was this like pure solution what people are finding now is no like the price of things are is based on psychology to a large degree and the way people behave in auctions is not you know as john nash would have wanted. And so what really matters is modeling the people involved and knowing sort of what their value is, whether that's rational or not, and then working within the confines of that. So if we're in an auction situation, it's playing the best response to the other people, you know, whatever auction strategy they're doing.
所以在房地产纠纷的情况下，你有两个人或更多人，他们有不同的价值观，你必须在合理化这种纠纷时考虑到这些价值观。我认为这些价值观很难编纂，因为它涉及很多常识推理、人性以及这些你不会写进智能合约的东西。我的意思是，是的，你说到点子上了。我向技术人员解释这些事情的方式是，看，我们几千年来一直在试图弄清楚什么是正义，什么是公平，
And so in the case of like a real estate dispute, you have two people or maybe more people who have different sets of values and you have to take those sets of values into account when you're rationalizing this dispute. And I think those values are very hard to codify because it involves sort of a lot of common sense reasoning and human nature and these kind of things that you're not going to write in a smart contract. I mean, yeah, you hit the nail on the head. The way I explain these things to technologists is, look, you know, we've been trying for millennia to figure out what justice and what fairness is,
如果它真的像一点博弈论和几个算法那么简单，那么我们早就弄清楚了。你不会有自柏拉图时代以来的哲学家写关于正义的理论和原则，因为你可以把它们全部提炼成数学。但正如我所说，事情没那么简单。是的，我的意思是，我认为作为一个试图听取法律代码的技术人员，我不知道是不是“代码”这个词让我们感到困惑，但我记得在学校上法律课时，总是和CS系的人一起上，每个人总是试图弄清楚法律的漏洞是什么？比如，哦，你不允许倒卖门票，因为这违反了……
right? And if it were truly as simple as a little bit of game theory and a couple algorithms, then, you know, we would have figured this out a long time ago. You wouldn't have, you know, philosophers since the time of Plato writing about you know what are the theories and principles of justice because you could all just distill it down to to math but you know like I said things are things are not that simple yeah yeah I mean I think as a as a technologist trying to you sort of hear like the legal code maybe i don't know if it's just the word code that like throws us off but i remember you know when in in sort of school taking a class about about law and always you know having these people who were so i took it
现在完全合法了。但我认为听到教这门课的律师的沮丧感很有趣，他说，事情不是这样运作的。你知道，在陪审团或法官面前，有很多关于意图的东西。他们使用他们的自由裁量权来判断你试图做什么，以及法律——不是法律在实际英语中说了什么，那并不完美——但它实际上意味着什么？对，对。这就是我们所说的“合同精神”。你实际上是在看意图，而不仅仅是合同确切说了什么。这回到了DAO的问题，黑客违反了……
with mostly people who were in the cs department and everyone was always trying to figure out like what's the little loophole to the law? Like, oh, you're not allowed to scalp tickets because, you know, it's against the
合同的精神，合同的意图，但不一定违反了合同的条款。所以，是的，这很有趣。抱歉，我要说的是，有趣的是，这种情况的心理学在DAO中得到了体现。有以太坊，符号是ETH。但在硬分叉时，有些人不同意资金应该被撤销。所以他们保持了原样，那些资金仍然被盗。在……我想他们从未尝试过提取这笔钱，但理论上他们……
totally legal now um but i think it was interesting to me to kind of hear like the frustration from the lawyer who is teaching the class being like, that's not how this works. You know, that there is a lot about intent and stuff that has to go before a jury or a judge. And they use their discretion about what you were trying to do and what what the law not what the law just says in terms of actual English, which isn't perfect, but what does it actually mean? Right, right. And that's what we call the spirit of the contract, right? You're really looking at intent, not just exactly what the contract says, right? And that, you know, going back, that's basically exactly what happened to the DAO dow you know the the hacker violated the
可以。所以有一个平行或分叉版本的以太坊区块链，那些交易从未被撤销，从未被回滚和修复。这就是ETC，以太坊经典。所以你实际上可以生活在你想要的任何版本的世界里。但以价格作为人们投票支持的代表，以太坊代币今天的价格是……我不知道现在是多少，但大约是1000美元。我认为以太坊经典代币大约是30美元。所以很有趣的是，尽管你会说互联网大环境的氛围可能是我们想要这些不可篡改的区块链、加密、去中心化等所有东西。但当真正发生冲突且是他们的钱被盗时，他们实际上投票决定撤销不可篡改性。这由今天哪一个价值更高证明了这一点。太搞笑了，对吧？
spirit of the contract the intent of the contract but not necessarily the terms of the contract so yeah that makes so i mean it is interesting to look at i'm sorry what i was gonna say so so interestingly the kind of whatever psychology of the situation is somewhat played out, though, with specifically the Dow. So there's Ethereum that sort of symboled by the ETH. But at the time of the hard fork, some people didn't agree that the funds should be reversed. And so they kept the course where those funds are still stolen. And in the, you know, presumably that person's, I don't know, I think they haven't, they've never tried to withdraw the money, but in theory they
人们有所有这些概念和这些高层次的哲学理想。但当他们赔钱时，他们会生气。所有的理智和实用主义都回来了。但你是对的。如果你把DAO作为一个例子，在那之前，每个人都说“代码即法律”，无论智能合约说什么都是法律。但随后这个黑客进来做了一些没人预料到的事情，这在技术上并不违反代码，在技术上并不违反法律，但它违反了……
could. And so there is a parallel or forked version of the Ethereum blockchain where those transactions were never undone, were never sort of rolled back and fixed. And that's this ETC, the Ethereum classic. And so there's actually, you can live in either version of the world you want to. But taking price as a stand in for what people and popularity of which people voted for the I mean, the price of an Ethereum token today is like I don't know what it is right now, but like a thousand dollars. And I think Ethereum classic token is like $30. So it's interesting that despite the fact that you would say the vibe of the internet at large is probably that we want these immutable blockchain crypto decentralized, you know, all of the stuff. That when the push came to shove and it was their money that got stolen, they actually voted to sort of kind of undo the immutability. And that's proven out by which one's valued at what today. It's so funny, right?
社区的期望。所以是的，你有那些“代码即法律”的死硬派，然后你有所有这些突然说“不，我们得去找警察”的人。是的，见证讨论是如何进行的真的很有趣。无政府主义者突然呼吁政府干预。是的，这有点好笑。而且就像，你要打给什么警察？什么警察了解正在发生的事情？
Like people have all these concepts and these high level philosophical ideals. But when they lose money, they get angry. And all the sense and all the pragmatism comes rolling right back in. But you're right. Like if you do look at the DAO as an example right up until that time everyone was like code is law whatever the smart contract says is law but then this hacker comes in and does something no one expects that isn't technically against the code it's not technically against the law but it's against what it was against the
我觉得这种认为这个人是一个彻底的无政府主义者，然后在有暴力迹象的那一刻，他们就拨打911的想法。这在整个2017年一直是一个主题。是的，所以我说加密区块链领域真的很有趣，因为它不仅仅是技术，它带有太多的基础。比如，哦，你必须去中心化，哦，你必须这样做。肯定有反政府、无政府主义的倾向。所以我认为当一个人在考虑ICO或在这个领域工作时，也需要坐下来思考，社区会对此有何反应？这绝对是一个非常有趣的领域。一个问题，稍微回溯一下。我们谈了一些ICO，你能描述一下那是什么吗？
community's expectations right and so yes you have you know obviously these these hardcore people like code is law and then you have all these people who are suddenly like no we gotta run to the police yeah you know it was really funny to to kind of just witness how the discussion went down. Yeah, the anarchists suddenly were calling for government intervention. Yeah, it was kind of funny. Yeah. And it's like, well, what police are you going to call? Like, what police understand what's going on, right?
社区的期望，所以是的，你显然有那些坚定的信徒，认为代码即法律，然后你又有很多人突然说，不，我们得去找警察。是的，你知道，亲眼目睹讨论是如何进行的真的很有趣。是的，无政府主义者突然呼吁政府干预。是的，这有点滑稽。而且就像是，好吧，你要找什么警察？有什么警察能理解现在发生了什么吗？
I feel like this idea that this person is just a total anarchist, and then at the moment there's a hint of violence, they're calling 911. That's been kind of like a motif for the whole 2017. Yeah, so I'll say that the crypto blockchain space is really interesting because it know it it it's not just the technology it comes with so much underpinning right like oh you got to be decentralized oh you got to do this there's you know definitely like anti-government um anarchist tendencies and so I think when one is thinking about an ICO or when one works in this space, one also needs to sit there and think about, well, how is the community going to react to this? It's definitely a very interesting space to be in. One question to kind of circle back a bit. So we talked a little bit about Ios and uh uh can you kind of describe what that
我觉得这种人平时是个彻底的无政府主义者，但一旦出现一点暴力苗头，他们就拨打911，这几乎成了整个2017年的一个主题。是的，所以我想说加密货币和区块链领域真的很有趣，因为它不仅仅是技术，它还带有太多的基础理念，比如你必须去中心化，你必须这样做，这里肯定有反政府、无政府主义的倾向。所以我认为当一个人在考虑ICO或者在这个领域工作时，也需要坐下来思考，社区会对此有何反应？这绝对是一个非常有趣的领域。为了回到刚才的话题，我们谈了一些关于ICO的内容，你能描述一下它是什么吗？
is like like in other words how did even bitcoin bitcoin might be a special case i guess because it was so early but just how did these coins start like like like what does that mean like is it how do you like is it creating something out of nothing? Like, you know, kind of how does that actually work? Yeah, it kind of is. I mean, Bitcoin was, you know, someone published a bunch of code out there. They put it out there. It was accompanied by a white paper that, you know, described why they were doing this and how it worked. And slowly people just started mining and adopting it um and with all the other uh coins you know people are like well why do i have to you know mine or buy bitcoin i'm
就像……换句话说，比特币到底是怎么开始的？比特币可能是一个特例，因为它的出现太早了，但这些币到底是怎么开始的？这意味着什么？是无中生有吗？你知道，这到底是怎么运作的？是的，某种程度上确实是。我的意思是，比特币是有人发布了一堆代码。他们把它发布出来，并附带了一份白皮书，描述了他们为什么要这样做以及它是如何运作的。然后人们慢慢开始挖矿并采用它。而对于所有其他代币，人们会想，为什么我非要挖矿或购买比特币呢？我
going to create my own different types of coins those are all coins and and then you kind of had ethereum come along the interesting thing about eth about Ethereum is even though there is like a payment transactional value aspect to it, the special case of Ethereum is it's really a protocol in which you can build other things. Right. So you see all these applications being built on top of Ethereum, which actually increases the value of Ethereum. Most smart contracts today, for example, are done on Ethereum. Now, ICOs aren't really coins. We're getting into semantics here, but they're not really coins. They're more so tokens, right? tokens right and so uh you know part of the reason why this space evolved is because people wanted to for example uh go out there and do these interesting decentralized projects right
要创造我自己的不同类型的币，那些就是山寨币（altcoins）。然后以太坊出现了。以太坊有趣的地方在于，尽管它有支付交易价值的层面，但以太坊的特殊之处在于它实际上是一个可以构建其他东西的协议。没错。所以你看到所有这些应用程序都构建在以太坊之上，这实际上增加了以太坊的价值。例如，今天大多数智能合约都是在以太坊上完成的。现在，ICO 并不是真正的币。我们在这里讨论的是语义问题，但它们确实不是币。它们更多是代币（tokens），对吧？代币。所以，这个领域之所以发展，部分原因是人们想要，例如，去开展这些有趣的去中心化项目，对吧？
um maybe they wanted to create a decentralized internet or do this or do that and those types of projects to the extent they're projects, to the extent they're open source, to the extent they're decentralized, it's really hard to get funding for them. So, you know, you started getting, I think, you know, was one of the first, Dow was one of the first, but you started seeing more and more use in ico as a way to raise money for a project that otherwise might not be able to get traditional funding but might actually be an interesting project or infrastructure for the ecosystem and then obviously, it's basically exploded right now. You see everyone seems to want to ICO and get on the blockchain. They're traditional companies that their business model
嗯，也许他们想创建一个去中心化的互联网，或者做这个做那个。对于这些类型的项目，只要它们是项目，只要它们是开源的，只要它们是去中心化的，就很难为它们获得资金。所以，你开始看到，我认为，DAO 是最早的项目之一，但你开始看到 ICO 被越来越多地用作一种为项目筹集资金的方式，这些项目可能无法获得传统融资，但实际上可能是对生态系统有意义的项目或基础设施。然后很明显，它现在基本上爆发了。你看到每个人似乎都想进行 ICO 并进入区块链领域。有些传统公司，它们的商业模式
doesn't even need blockchain. They're trying to ICO. Now, I think a lot of this is driven by how frothy the market is. There's a ton of money in the space and a lot of people are just running after the money. But there still are, you know, a lot of really good projects out there that I think are critical to, you know, building out infrastructure of the space that, you know, if you go to Silicon Valley today,
甚至根本不需要区块链，它们也在尝试进行 ICO。现在，我认为这很大程度上是由市场的狂热程度驱动的。这个领域里有大量的资金，很多人只是在追逐金钱。但仍然有很多非常好的项目，我认为它们对于构建这个领域的基础设施至关重要，如果你今天去硅谷，
like you may not be able to get funding for it. So can you talk a little bit more like sort of concretely about what actually an ICO is? So is an ICO someone implementing like cloning Bitcoin, but for tokens? Like, yeah, like tactically, concretely, what's actually going on? So it can be a number of different things. Usually it's, you know, either a company or a project that is going out
你可能无法为它们获得资金。那么你能更具体地谈谈什么是 ICO 吗？所以 ICO 是有人在实现类似克隆比特币的东西，但针对的是代币？是的，从战术上、具体上来说，到底发生了什么？它可以是很多不同的事情。通常是公司或项目方
and they're either building a DApp, which is, you know, an application on top of a protocol, or they're actually building a protocol themselves and they are using an ICO as a means of funding it, right? So usually the way they go about this is they will write a white paper. It's kind of a high-level concept paper that gives you a bit of details about how the project would be technically feasible. They will go and assemble a team, right?
要么在构建一个 DApp（即协议之上的应用程序），要么他们实际上是在构建一个协议本身，并利用 ICO 作为筹集资金的手段，对吧？所以通常他们这样做的方式是写一份白皮书。这是一种高层概念文件，为你提供了一些关于该项目在技术上如何可行的细节。他们会去组建一个团队，对吧？
So you've got the founding team. You've probably got a group of advisors. And then, of course, everything else is, you know, the money-raising process you've got to get your legal together, your marketing together. Community tends to be, or building a community tends to be really important space. That's how you show traction. I actually think one of the most difficult things that people
所以你有创始团队。你可能有一群顾问。然后，当然，其他一切都是筹款过程，你必须准备好法律文件、市场营销。社区往往是，或者说建立一个社区在这个领域非常重要。这就是你展示吸引力的方式。我实际上认为人们在进行 ICO 时
don't think about enough when they are going out and launching an ICO is their token economics, right? I think over this last summer, I had an intern go and research a bunch of ICUs for me and pull together for me their token economics. And when I sat down to look at it, you literally had everything across the map, all different types of allocations, all different types of systems. It was kind of like someone took a shot of tequila and threw a dart against a dartboard. There was no art or science to this. But basically, folks are going out and they're saying, hey, we're going to release X number of tokens. And these are what the tokens will be used for. Sometimes they have some sort of utility like membership or ability to use someone's platform.
考虑得不够多的一件最困难的事情是他们的代币经济学，对吧？我想去年夏天，我让一个实习生去为我研究了一堆 ICO，并为我整理了它们的代币经济学。当我坐下来看的时候，你简直看到了各种各样的东西，各种不同的分配方式，各种不同的系统。这就像有人喝了一杯龙舌兰酒，然后往飞镖盘上扔飞镖。这既没有艺术性也没有科学性。但基本上，人们走出来说，嘿，我们要发行 X 数量的代币。这些就是代币的用途。有时它们具有某种实用性，比如会员资格或使用某人平台的能力。
You know, they might be like pre-sold credits to a platform, something like that, right? That the possibilities are endless. But I think one of the problems today is that people are going out, they you know guessing on this this like mini digital token economy that they're going to try and manage and um i don't think a lot of people have thought deeply about okay how can we make this scalable not for a couple hundred users or a couple thousand users but for a couple millions of users and when you reach that point and your token economics breaks down i think people are going to have a lot of issues well i mean you point out it's even interesting to see that some some but some people want
你知道，它们可能就像是平台的预售积分，诸如此类，对吧？可能性是无限的。但我认为今天的问题之一是，人们正在猜测这种他们试图管理的迷你数字代币经济，而且我不认为很多人深入思考过，好吧，我们如何使它具有可扩展性，不是针对几百个用户或几千个用户，而是针对几百万个用户。当你达到那个点而你的代币经济学崩溃时，我认为人们会遇到很多问题。嗯，我的意思是，你指出甚至很有趣的是，有些人想要
inflationary economics and some people want deflationary economics and so it doesn't even seem people are settled out about what should happen over the long term oh yeah i mean so you see so many interesting creative different models right people are burning tokens which means like they kind of get rid get um cut out from the the finance supply yeah it's um yeah like i said human beings are creative man so um do you can i don't know if you if you can speak to it but i mean i know last year the sec also came out with an opinion about this notion of you know tokens and coins as a security versus being used as utilities. So now you see this sort of bandied about like things that are security tokens versus things that are utility tokens.
通胀型经济学，而有些人想要通缩型经济学，所以人们似乎甚至没有就长期应该发生什么达成一致。哦，是的，我的意思是，你看到了这么多有趣、有创意、不同的模型，对吧？人们在销毁代币，这意味着他们从金融供应中剔除它们。是的，就像我说的，人类很有创造力。那么，我不知道你是否能谈谈，但我知道去年美国证券交易委员会（SEC）也发表了关于代币和币作为证券与作为实用工具的观点。所以现在你看到这种说法被到处引用，比如什么是证券代币，什么是实用代币。
And like, what does that mean for someone who wants to kind of participate in them in the US, but specifically about someone who would want to sort of do their own, you know, coin offering or token offering or whatever? Yeah, sure. So, you know, in the early the early days of icos there was this rampant rumor running around that it was completely unregulated which was not the case um i think a lot of technologists who were doing icos just didn't know there were laws uh in in capital raising and so the sec on july 27th of 2017 came out and was like hey you guys actually the same old securities laws apply so you know if your ico raise or whatever you're doing whatever you want to call it um looks like it's a securities offering, you still have to follow the US securities laws. And they've basically reiterated that position in, you know, several statements since then.
那么，对于那些想在美国参与这些项目的人，特别是对于那些想进行自己的代币发行的人来说，这意味着什么？当然。所以，在 ICO 的早期，有一个猖獗的谣言说它是完全不受监管的，事实并非如此。我认为很多做 ICO 的技术人员只是不知道在资本筹集方面有法律规定。因此，美国证券交易委员会在 2017 年 7 月 27 日出来说，嘿，你们这些家伙，实际上同样的旧证券法适用。所以，如果你的 ICO 筹款或你正在做的任何事情，无论你想怎么称呼它，看起来像是证券发行，你仍然必须遵守美国证券法。从那以后，他们在几份声明中基本上重申了这一立场。
Now, I think there is this rumor running around that a utility token cannot be a security token and that they are mutually exclusive. And that is actually not the case. You know, you can definitely have a token that is a security, but has some sort of utility function. Now, in terms of where that bright line is, it's really hard to say, right? Everyone's still sitting here waiting for the SEC to clarify a little bit more on what exactly all of this means. So, you know, anyone who's thinking about doing the ICO should definitely hire counsel and make sure that they're doing things in a compliant manner. I always say, you know, it's not necessarily the SEC that you have to be looking out for.
现在，我认为有一个谣言说实用代币不可能是证券代币，它们是互斥的。事实并非如此。你知道，你绝对可以拥有一个既是证券又具有某种实用功能的代币。至于那条明确的界限在哪里，真的很难说，对吧？每个人都还在坐等 SEC 对这一切到底意味着什么做出更明确的解释。所以，任何考虑进行 ICO 的人都应该聘请法律顾问，并确保他们以合规的方式行事。我总是说，你不一定非要提防 SEC。
You also should be looking out for state regulators and the plaintiff's bar, right? Now, in terms of for investors, how this affects them, you know, it is very possible for investors to invest in an ICO that's compliant with securities law. We have the JOBS Act, which for the first time in basically forever allows non-accredited, so basically not rich investors to invest in private securities offerings. Specifically, the two regulations that allow for this are regulation crowdfunding and regulation A+. So to the extent an ICO is selling their tokens in the United States, and it is a regulatory exemption like the ones I mentioned. If they don't, they'd
你还应该提防州监管机构和原告律师，对吧？现在，对于投资者来说，这如何影响他们，你知道，投资者完全有可能投资于符合证券法的 ICO。我们有《JOBS 法案》，它基本上是有史以来第一次允许非合格投资者，也就是基本上不是富有的投资者，投资于私募证券发行。具体来说，允许这样做的两项法规是众筹法规（Regulation Crowdfunding）和 A+ 法规（Regulation A+）。如果 ICO 在美国销售其代币，并且它属于我提到的那种监管豁免。如果他们不这样做，他们要么
either be violating the law or they can only sell to people outside of the U.S. The SEC, their jurisdiction is really only with U.S. investors. They only care about protecting U.S. investors. Foreign only care about protecting U.S. investors. You know, for investors, they don't really care. And then I guess just for people who may not know that SEC is Securities and Exchange Commission. Yes. And they're traditionally the people who make sure that stocks and brokerages and options and futures people all do the things they're supposed to and
违反法律，要么他们只能向美国境外的人出售。SEC 的管辖权实际上仅限于美国投资者。他们只关心保护美国投资者。外国……只关心保护美国投资者。你知道，对于投资者来说，他们并不真正关心。我想对于那些可能不知道 SEC 是证券交易委员会的人来说。是的。他们传统上是确保股票、经纪业务、期权和期货从业者都做他们应该做的事情的人，并且
regulate them and investigate fraud. Yeah. And, you know, every state also has its own version of the SEC. So there are state securities regulators. And obviously there is like the equivalent of an SEC in every other country. right? So even if you are selling to foreign investors, maybe you don't have to deal with the US SEC, but you might have to deal with the New Zealand's version of the SEC or Japan's version of the SEC. And some countries have been very, have come to embrace this whole ICO phenomena and other countries have actually taken a much more drastic stance than the SEC. So for example, China has pretty much banned ICOs. So this is an interesting thing that you also see on the internet. Like there's this, so I happen
监管他们并调查欺诈行为。是的。而且，你知道，每个州也有自己的 SEC 版本。所以有州证券监管机构。显然，每个其他国家都有相当于 SEC 的机构，对吧？所以即使你是在向外国投资者销售，也许你不需要处理美国的 SEC，但你可能需要处理新西兰版的 SEC 或日本版的 SEC。有些国家已经非常拥抱整个 ICO 现象，而其他国家则采取了比 SEC 更激进的立场。例如，中国几乎禁止了 ICO。所以这是你在互联网上看到的有趣的事情。比如，我碰巧
to know, like you pointed out, that people in the U.S. will sort of do an ICO and say, you know, not open to U.S. investors. And then there's this kind of belief that, like, if I put some disclaimers on my page, that's kind of good enough. From a legal standpoint, does it kind of work that way? Or, like, if someone in New Zealand does invest because they didn't know, but that disclaimer was there, said, like, don't invest if this is illegal in your country. Like, how does that work out? Like, is it the burden on the person offering the security to check? Yes. And so that's why we have these wonderful AML KYC laws. AML is anti money laundering. KYC is know your customer. It basically the function of these laws is to know the identity of the investor and make sure you know the identity of that or make sure that investor isn't like on some terrorist watch list or something
知道，正如你指出的，美国的人会进行 ICO 并说，你知道，不对美国投资者开放。然后有一种信念，认为如果我在我的页面上放一些免责声明，那就足够了。从法律角度来看，它是那样运作的吗？或者，如果新西兰有人因为不知道而投资了，但那里有免责声明，说如果这在你的国家是非法的，就不要投资。那它是怎么运作的？提供证券的人是否有责任去核实？是的。这就是为什么我们有这些美妙的反洗钱（AML）和了解你的客户（KYC）法律。AML 是反洗钱。KYC 是了解你的客户。这些法律的功能基本上是了解投资者的身份，并确保你知道该身份，或者确保该投资者不在某些恐怖分子观察名单上，或者诸如此类
or you know accused money laundering or anything like that citizen up right and so um people really should be doing accurate aml kyc checks um i've definitely seen icos less so nowadays but more so in the early wild west days where folks were like okay i'm just gonna like write this on my website or in this paperwork that no one's ever gonna really read and you know we're still gonna take u.s investors anyway we don't really care um some people you know will block u.s investors out by their ip address but then of course you know people will go and get a vpn yeah um it's really interesting last friday on the 17th um the massachusetts securities regulators came out and uh did a enforcement action against an ico uh run by a citizen of Massachusetts. And apparently an investigator had gone in to the system
或者你知道被指控洗钱之类的。对吧？所以人们真的应该进行准确的 AML/KYC 检查。我绝对见过 ICO，现在少了，但在早期的狂野西部时代更多，当时人们就像，好吧，我只是要在我的网站上或在没人会真正阅读的文件中写下这一点，而且你知道，我们仍然会接受美国投资者，反正我们并不真正关心。有些人会通过 IP 地址阻止美国投资者，但当然，你知道，人们会去获取 VPN。是的。这真的很有趣，上周五，17 号，马萨诸塞州的证券监管机构出来并对一个由马萨诸塞州公民运营的 ICO 采取了执法行动。显然，一名调查员进入了系统
to try to buy into the ICO. And the system purported to have AML-KYC. So the investigator put in a fake name know name like mickey mouse or something like that and then when they uh uh you know showed a picture of their their government id that name did not match the name that they had put in but they still got approved 29 minutes later and so the investigator was able to buy into the ico so you know that was obviously an aml kyc fail yeah see didn't i tell you about human beings being creative yeah uh i want to make comments here about i'll refrain from my commentary and on other companies
试图购买该 ICO。该系统声称拥有 AML/KYC。所以调查员输入了一个假名字，比如米老鼠之类的，然后当他们展示他们的政府身份证照片时，那个名字与他们输入的名字不符，但他们仍然在 29 分钟后获得了批准。所以调查员能够买入该 ICO。所以，你知道，那显然是一个 AML/KYC 的失败。是的，看，我不是告诉过你人类很有创造力吗？是的。我想在这里发表评论，但我会克制自己不对其他公司
doing shady things but uh yeah it wouldn't be the first time that that company's done so how does ico so is ico would you consider it like the yeah there was a lot of crowdfunding has been around forever right i mean the idea of sort of Groupon evolved from people who would in person get together and form a coalition. And this actually literally happens in Japan. Maybe not so much anymore. But this is sort of the genesis of Groupon was in Japan, people, you know, 100 people would go to a TV store and say, all 100 of us will buy a TV right now, but you have to give us a 30% discount. That literally happened. And so crowdfunding has been around forever, that kind of idea. And then it really took off on the internet with Kickstarter and things like that. And so do you see ICOs as sort of like the next evolution of crowdfunding? Or, you know, is it related in any way?
做阴暗的事情发表评论，但是的，那家公司做这种事已经不是第一次了。那么 ICO 是……你会认为它就像……众筹已经存在很久了，对吧？我的意思是，Groupon 的想法是从人们亲自聚在一起并组成联盟演变而来的。这实际上确实发生在日本。也许现在没那么多了。但这正是 Groupon 在日本的起源，人们，你知道，100 个人会去一家电视商店说，我们 100 个人现在都要买一台电视，但你必须给我们 30% 的折扣。这确实发生过。所以众筹已经存在很久了，那种想法。然后它在互联网上随着 Kickstarter 之类的东西真正起飞了。所以你认为 ICO 是众筹的下一次进化吗？或者，你知道，它有什么关联吗？
Oh, absolutely. I mean, ICOs are one subset of crowdfunding, right? There's so many different types of crowdfunding, you can do donation based rewards based, you know, equity or debt crowdfunding, you can do token crowd crowdfunding which to me is basically an ico um and you're right crowdfunding has been around for a long time the statue of liberty you can say was actually crowdfunded right so uh icos are just you know i suppose a newer, trendier way to do crowdfunding if you have a blockchain-related project or start. Oh, so what's the connection with the... I mean, I get that an ICO kind of runs on top of the blockchain, but you could use it to crowdfund anything, right? I mean, technically you could.
哦，绝对是。我的意思是，ICO 是众筹的一个子集，对吧？众筹有这么多不同的类型，你可以做基于捐赠的、基于奖励的、你知道，股权或债务众筹，你可以做代币众筹，对我来说这基本上就是 ICO。而且你是对的，众筹已经存在很长时间了，自由女神像可以说实际上就是众筹的，对吧？所以 ICO 只是，你知道，我想如果你有一个区块链相关的项目或初创公司，这是一种更新、更时髦的众筹方式。哦，那么它与……有什么联系？我的意思是，我明白 ICO 是在区块链之上运行的，但你可以用它来众筹任何东西，对吧？我的意思是，从技术上讲你可以。
There's definitely a lot of businesses today that are like, oh, we're going to go do an ICO, right? But one of the questions, one of the first questions you're going to get from any sort of ICO investor is, why is your business, why is blockchain necessary for your business, right? And then question number two will be, why is tokenization necessary for your business or project? And you do have to have really good answers to both of those. Oh, I see. So how does Dogecoin answer those questions? So Dogecoin really is a... No, I'm just... If you have a serious answer, I mean, you can answer, but I was more joking.
今天绝对有很多企业说，哦，我们要去进行 ICO，对吧？但其中一个问题，任何 ICO 投资者会问你的第一个问题是，为什么你的业务，为什么区块链对你的业务是必要的，对吧？然后第二个问题是，为什么代币化对你的业务或项目是必要的？你确实必须对这两个问题都有非常好的答案。哦，我明白了。那么狗狗币（Dogecoin）是如何回答这些问题的？所以狗狗币确实是一个……不，我只是……如果你有一个严肃的答案，我的意思是，你可以回答，但我更多是在开玩笑。
But I guess, I mean, if I was making anything, I don't know, cookies or a video game or whatever, couldn't I just say, you're buying one copy of this thing whenever it's done? I mean, you could i mean i know a guy up in sf who's he's tokenizing parties you know um you have to have at least 100 tokens to come to my party um you can't do it for anything but you know obviously you know not everything is a great idea to to tokenize that's why the price of gs has gone so high because everyone's trying to get into this guy's party and they just can't get in. Yeah, but you have to also remember,
但我猜，我的意思是，如果我在制作任何东西，我不知道，饼干或电子游戏什么的，我难道不能直接说，只要它完成了，你就买一份吗？我的意思是，你可以。我的意思是，我认识一个旧金山的人，他正在将派对代币化。你知道，你必须至少有 100 个代币才能来参加我的派对。你不能为了任何事情而做，但你知道，显然，并不是所有东西都适合代币化。这就是为什么 GS 的价格涨得那么高，因为每个人都想参加这个人的派对，但他们就是进不去。是的，但你也必须记住，
like when you do something like, you know, put your business on the blockchain, it does also bring a lot of complexity to what you're doing. It does increase costs a lot, right, on security and things like that. So that's one thing I would caution folks about is, you know, maybe you might be able to get some funding from this cool thing, but you better have great justification because it's going to bring a lot more cost and complexity as well. Yeah, actually, now that you mention it, I guess, how is an ICO different from me just saying, oh, I guess the ICO is...
当你做像把你的业务放在区块链上这样的事情时，它确实也会给你的工作带来很多复杂性。它确实大大增加了成本，对吧，在安全等方面。所以这是我会提醒人们的一件事，你知道，也许你可能能从这个很酷的东西中获得一些资金，但你最好有很好的理由，因为它也会带来更多的成本和复杂性。是的，实际上，既然你提到了，我想，ICO 和我只是说，哦，我想 ICO 是……有什么不同？
Yeah, in other words, how is an ICO different than me just saying, PayPal me $10 and I'll send you this game when it's ready or something like that. I mean, I guess PayPal is a centralized system. I mean, so, you know, if I could generalize about ICOs today, a lot of them will come out and sell their tokens for a limited amount of time. And part of the reason why they do that is psychology, right? You're creating FOMO, fear of missing out. You know, EOS is one protocol that basically did an ICO, but they did it for a year long. I think they still might be doing it. And
是的，换句话说，ICO 和我只是说，给我 PayPal 10 美元，等游戏准备好了我就发给你，有什么不同？我的意思是，我想 PayPal 是一个中心化系统。我的意思是，所以，你知道，如果我可以概括今天的 ICO，很多会出来并在有限的时间内出售他们的代币。他们这样做的部分原因是心理学，对吧？你在制造 FOMO，错失恐惧症。你知道，EOS 是一个基本上进行了 ICO 的协议，但他们进行了一年。我想他们可能还在进行。而且
they're basically selling like $20 million worth of tokens every day. They've raised insane amounts. But most ICOs out there are for a very short, limited amount of time. And so, you know, they want people to flock to them really quick. And, you know, it's supposed to be this whole limited time opportunity as opposed to, oh, well, you can buy it whenever you want. Oh, I see. Got it. So, Amy, before we wind up, is there anything more you want to say about, like, dispute resolution, where you think the future is, advice for people? Yeah, so I would say, you know, to the extent any of your listeners are involved in the crypto space, one of the next things that we're actually pushing out is a dispute resolution intake form. You know, I get a lot of random direct messages on Twitter and emails from disgruntled people in the crypto space who, surprise, surprise, have lost money. And so they're unhappy and they're looking for help.
他们基本上每天都在卖出价值 2000 万美元的代币。他们筹集了惊人的金额。但大多数 ICO 的时间都非常短、非常有限。所以，你知道，他们希望人们迅速涌向他们。而且，你知道，这应该是一个限时机会，而不是，哦，好吧，你可以随时购买。哦，我明白了。懂了。那么，艾米，在我们结束之前，关于争议解决、你认为未来在哪里、给人们的建议，你还有什么想说的吗？是的，所以我会说，你知道，如果你的任何听众参与了加密货币领域，我们实际上正在推出的下一件事之一是一个争议解决申请表。你知道，我在 Twitter 上收到很多随机的私信，还有来自加密货币领域不满人士的电子邮件，他们，惊喜惊喜，赔钱了。所以他们很不高兴，正在寻求帮助。
And, you know, I just wanted to find a way to aggregate all of these claims so that we might actually be able to help people. So whether it's against an ICO or whether you have a grievance against exchange or whatever, people can go to the intake form, which is sagewise.io forward slash dispute. So that's S-A-G-E-W-I-S-E dot I-O forward slash dispute. And, you know, let us know what you have issues or concerns within the space and we are trying to see if we can help you know um i i think uh in order for the industry to succeed we have to you know hold people accountable and make sure they're not scamming other people. So, you know, I would personally love to, to hear what's happening, what's going on in the community.
而且，你知道，我只是想找到一种方法来汇总所有这些索赔，这样我们也许真的能帮助人们。所以无论是针对 ICO，还是你对交易所或其他什么有不满，人们都可以去申请表，网址是 sagewise.io 斜杠 dispute。所以是 S-A-G-E-W-I-S-E 点 I-O 斜杠 dispute。而且，你知道，让我们知道你在该领域有什么问题或担忧，我们正在尝试看看我们是否能帮助你。你知道，嗯，我认为为了让这个行业成功，我们必须，你知道，让人们负责，并确保他们没有诈骗其他人。所以，你知道，我个人很想听听正在发生什么，社区里正在发生什么。
Awesome. And then what's it like to, you know, kind of work at Sagewise? You're looking for programmers? I mean, maybe we have people who are lawyers who are listening. Yeah, are you looking for legal, you know, aides to help you and all of that? Oh, gosh. Well, we'll definitely be looking for interns. We actually do plan on hiring two developers in the near-term future, one back and one front end. I'm also looking for a chief of staff to help me out on the business marketing overall strategy side. So, yes, we're definitely hiring and if people are just interested to follow our progress and see what happens um you can you know they can find me in all the traditional social media channels so
太棒了。那么在 SageWise 工作是什么感觉？你在找程序员吗？我的意思是，也许我们有律师在听。是的，你在找法律助理来帮助你吗？哦，天哪。嗯，我们肯定会寻找实习生。我们确实计划在短期内招聘两名开发人员，一名后端，一名前端。我还正在寻找一名幕僚长来帮助我处理业务营销的整体战略方面。所以，是的，我们绝对在招聘，如果人们只是有兴趣关注我们的进展并看看会发生什么，嗯，你可以，你知道，他们可以在所有传统的社交媒体渠道找到我，所以
linkedin twitter i i'm in a lot of the Facebook crypto groups, Instagram, right? And if they want to, you know, follow our progress for SageWise, they can join our telegram at t.co forward slash SageWise. All right. Very awesome. Thank you so much. I mean, this has been, you know, we've never talked to a lawyer on the show before. So, yeah, congratulations. You're the first one. Or I guess. Anyway, it doesn't matter. And, you know, it's definitely an interesting and pertinent thing today. I mean, I know lots of people out there have at least, you know, heard about cryptocurrency and wondered what smart contracts were. And so I think this is this is a great help to people. Yeah, I feel like personally, there are certain things that are kind of just really hard to grasp for me. And you kind of like I've been, you know, on the earth long enough now that I kind of can gauge where I am in understanding something. And so, for example uh like eigenvectors so eigenvectors were the sort of really nebulous thing i couldn't really you know understand it
LinkedIn、Twitter，我加入了许多 Facebook 加密货币群组，Instagram，对吧？如果他们想，你知道，关注我们 SageWise 的进展，他们可以加入我们的 Telegram，网址是 t.co 斜杠 SageWise。好的。非常棒。非常感谢。我的意思是，这已经，你知道，我们以前从未在节目中采访过律师。所以，是的，恭喜。你是第一个。或者我猜。无论如何，没关系。而且，你知道，这在今天绝对是一个有趣且相关的话题。我的意思是，我知道外面很多人至少，你知道，听说过加密货币，并想知道智能合约是什么。所以我认为这对人们有很大帮助。是的，我个人觉得，有些事情对我来说真的很难掌握。而且你有点像，你知道，我在地球上待的时间够长了，现在我可以衡量我在理解某事方面的水平。所以，例如，嗯，像特征向量（eigenvectors），所以特征向量是一种非常模糊的东西，我无法真正，你知道，理解它
and then it was like okay i could see how people were using it but but i couldn't like under the hood it just didn't it wasn't part of the fabric i guess of, of my consciousness. I couldn't really connect eigenvectors. I was choosing that kind of at random. It's like everything else I know, right? And then eventually I kind of figured it out, right? And so the same with, let's say, probably density functions or something, right? And so I feel like ICOs and blockchain, like blockchain at this point, I have a pretty good idea. But ICOs and, you know,
然后就像，好吧，我可以看到人们是如何使用它的，但我无法，在底层，它只是没有，它不是我意识结构的一部分。我无法真正连接特征向量。我当时是随机选择的。就像我知道的其他一切一样，对吧？然后最终我弄明白了，对吧？所以对于，比如说，概率密度函数之类的东西也是一样，对吧？所以我个人觉得 ICO 和区块链，就像区块链在这一点上，我有一个相当不错的概念。但 ICO 和，你知道，
cryptocurrencies and these things, it's just, I feel like personally, it's just really hard to wrap my head around, you know, kind of what is actually going on. But I think I have a much better idea now than I did an hour ago. And I feel like I'm going to wake up tomorrow with like a ton of questions and
加密货币和这些东西，我个人觉得，真的很难理解，你知道，到底发生了什么。但我认为我现在比一小时前有了更好的了解。而且我觉得我明天醒来时会有很多问题，而且
so are probably a lot of other people and don't hesitate to ping Amy or message on Google Plus and I'll point Amy to our post on Google Plus and Facebook and all of that so if you have any questions for her you know she'll
可能还有很多人也是这样，不要犹豫，去 ping 艾米或在 Google Plus 上留言，我会把艾米指向我们在 Google Plus 和 Facebook 等平台上的帖子，所以如果你有任何问题要问她，你知道，她会
know where to go look for that and yeah thank you so much for coming on. This is fascinating. Fantastic. Thanks so much for having me. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license.
知道去哪里看。是的，非常感谢你来参加。这太迷人了。太棒了。非常感谢邀请我。片头音乐是 Binar Pilot 的 Axo。Programming Throwdown 是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发的。
You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传播该作品，进行重混、改编，但你必须注明 Patrick 和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。